indignados por los acontecimientos
actuales que han llevado de nuevo al
juez tarek vetar a tener que suspender
la investigación del puerto de berut los
familiares de las víctimas de las
explosiones del 4 de agosto de 2020 han
venido hoy aquí al palacio de justicia a
exigir que se ponga fin a la instrucción
deliberada de la justicia el fiscal
general
que es uno de los imputados decidió ayer
de forma unánime liberar a todos los
encausados en el proceso e inhabilitar
al juez encargado de la investigación
que este mismo lunes había reabierto el
caso para procesar al ex Primer Ministro
libanés hasandiab así como altos mandos
de la seguridad general como el general
avas y brahim y también a pesos pesados
de la justicia como guaydad
vital se ha enfrentado al fiscal general
verbalmente y le ha dicho que nos va a
parar la investigación y que su deber
con los libaneses que se haga justicia
precisamente organizaciones
internacionales como amnistía
internacional han acusado a las
autoridades libanesas de no querer
participar en el proceso al no levantar
la inmunidad política de los encausados
más de 220 personas murieron en las
explosiones causadas por la detonación
de más de 2.000 toneladas de nitrato de
amonio que estaban almacenadas sin
ningún tipo de seguridad durante años en
un hangar en el puerto de beirut un
incidente trágico que está considerado
como un crimen de negligencia por parte
de las autoridades libanesas que no
quieren ver que se vea y que salga la
luz